I hope you enjoyed this course and to
help you complete it I want to make sure
that there are a few course resources
that you know about first if you have
any questions or you want to discuss
anything with the classmates or the
teaching staff including me or if you
want to file a bug report the best place
to do that is the discussion forum the
teaching staff and I will be modeling
that regularly and this is also a good
place for you to get answers to your
questions from your classmates or if you
wish try to answer your classmates
questions to get to the discussion forum
from this course homepage if you look at
this menu bar on the left you also might
look a bit different than mine but
they'll do this discussion forum tab
which give you click on gives you to the
discussion forum the best way to ask
questions is on the discussion forum but
it for some reason you need to contact
us directly or let us know about some
problem feel free also to email us at
this email address I promise we will
read every email and we'll try to
address commonly occurring issues
although depending on the email volume I
can't guarantee that we'll be able to
reply promptly to every email but we
will read every email that you send next
I know that there are other companies
that wish to train maybe large numbers
of employees would be learning if you're
responsible for employee training in
your company and would like to train a
hundred or more employees with deep
learning expertise please feel free to
get in touch at this email and we'll see
if we can help you we're just in the
early phases of developing the
university academic program but if
you're a university instructor or a
university administrator interested in
offering a deep learning course at your
university please feel free to contact
us at this email address so I hope that
gives you more resources to complete the
course maybe I'll see some of you in the
discussion forums and best of luck